um this afternoon's talk um is by Lucas
Durand uh he uses he him his pronouns he
is the director of data science
engineering at TD Securities the title
of his talk is building interactive
Network graphs to understand communities
and we'll be using uh various python
libraries to do that let's welcome
him awesome thank you so much thanks the
intro it was great um I look forward to
communicating with you throughout time
and everything awesome so hey everyone
thanks for coming um lots of great talks
on today so I'm really pleased that you
came to see mine um makes me feel warm
inside I'm also drinking some hot tea so
that also makes me feel warm inside but
uh I think it's mostly for you um okay
so there's a couple different components
of what I want to go over today really
the focus is about trying to understand
people we're going to use some Network
graph libraries in Python and then also
take a big focus on visualization um
there's notebooks uh you can follow
along run the code uh you can either
just look at the solutions or try to
write it out there's some like little
challenge problems kind of out as well
depending on what your your feel is um
but the summary of the whole thing is on
this uh GitHub Pages page uh that uh is
served at my website if you are having
trouble seeing what the URL is it's
linked in the a schedule piece at the
bottom there's like a link to this page
and then this page has links to all the
other pages that you might need um so
lots of blinks um and yeah let's jump
into it uh I want to talk to you today
about Network wraps uh and I'm really
sorry we're going to start off with some
slides um but you know let's ground the
problem a little bit uh with colorful
things that I've previously done and
want to reuse um awesome so what do we
want to do today a couple different
things uh Point number one is actually
happening right now um I'm telling you
about this topic it's the introduction
is happening I'm going to tell you about
myself as well then we're going to
create a graph um it's going to be about
people then we're going to do a little
bit more advanced graph piece to try and
solve problem that's going to arise um
so we're going to try and cluster
attributes within the graph um after
that we're going to build a little
application that would let you find your
peers in an organization um and I'll
talk more about that later um in theory
there's a conclusion too but I'm not
sure if I actually plan that all right
so we'll see when we get there so who am
I um I'm Lucas Grant um I'm a data
scientist software engineer um
passionate python user as well my
pronouns are he him his uh and yeah a
bit of my background uh I was a
theoretical physicist uh for a number of
years really enjoyed that and then
decided I might try something a little
bit different see what industry is like
and then accidentally ended up as a
Quant in an investment bank and thought
that's not so bad that uh I might keep
trying this and maybe do some more
coding and fell into data science
software engineering uh and continue do
that today um so I'm with this place
called TD Securities the TD stands for
Toronto Dominion uh it's a Investment
Bank a wholesale Bank based out of
Toronto but we have a giant office here
in New York um and for some reason it's
one of the 10 largest banks in America
for some reason um even though we're in
trouble so you know capitalism is crazy
you know it's crazy um oh yeah my
instrument of choice is a saxophone love
to play sax um that's me at some like
charity dig trying to raise money for um
like not just for like people who play
the Sachs who do need money like please
support them but mostly for actual
registered Charities um so I love that
in my spare time and I also love uh
learning about Python and yeah there's a
little picture of me at uh a Pyon I
think it was uh in Cleveland I want to
say um and I'm like looking really
interested in this talk with the beer
and it's like great I'm looking forward
to doing that later in this week um so
that'll be great okay so that's me maybe
like who this is why you care about me
but I want to talk about the problem now
um and it's about finding your people
where are they right you just joined a
big company some big Bank some big
Telecom some insurance company
healthcare provider I don't know what it
is whatever the big places are there's a
lot of people potentially a lot of
people who have the same job title as
you potentially job titles don't align
very well with what people are working
on maybe you're a software develop and
you use Python which like I think a
chunk of people in here might be um okay
that's fun um but hey there's lots of
other software developers who don't use
Python is that written down somewhere
how do we find that out how do I find
people who like the kind of things that
I like anyways you probably started
somewhere with a laptop maybe a Wiki
page that says like do this to get
access to everything um which is pretty
useful um and then at least where I was
we had this like kind of kind of useful
social tool which was like a a really
bad knockoff of like early Facebook um
and you could go and see like who your
manager was which I hope you already
knew um and then like who they managed
as well and you can kind of iteratively
climb through this this tree structure
and find out more about the or structure
right the like reporting hierarchy of
the organization and that was kind of
useful but uh it's not enough so a
couple different things were happening
same manager um is good but uh it's hard
to really like find anyone outside of
that there's a lot of clicks involved um
so like let's at least scrape this API
and put into some other format right um
in our case uh we have a global company
and Regional teams all aligned to a
regional CIO and so the folks on my that
I work with in Dublin uh are actually
hugely distant from me I have to click
like 18 times to get to them but I see
them every day so like that's not very
useful this this this is lying to us
about how close together we really are
right um if you work in like a
a situation with agile pods which like
our company's also starting to do right
now on the side you might have everyone
in the same job family aligned together
you might have like software developers
or like business analysts or
visualization experts all in one pod
which is great everyone in your pod
theoretically has the same job title now
so you know where they all are right but
you might be working on different things
it might not be like again like python
isn't the only way that you do software
development um but you've lost this idea
of like more traditional hierarchy which
is Project based so you might not be
working on the same things but like yeah
they might be closer to your people that
actually might be useful just as a an
abstraction for how you set up a company
um and the last one um which really
applies to people the data space and the
python space uh is that Niche roles are
often alone on a team a lot of the time
you get these like embedded um experts
in a team it's like oh I'm going to have
a data scientist and a data engineer on
my team for six months and they're going
to do all the pipelines and they're
going to do all the analytics um and
then they're going to leave um but you
know they don't we don't see them as
part of our organization on paper right
so traditional orc chart is not working
for us what is better than
that great question so I mean what I'm
going to say the answer is is we're
going to put them into a network graph
right uh so the basics that we want to
cover before we dive more into this is
like what is a graph um let's keep it
simple and let's talk about three
components and there's nodes these are
actual like well there's a couple names
for them vertices points nodes but they
contain information they're like rows in
our database um or like U entries in our
dictionary something like that and they
have different attributes associated
with them they are data points they can
also be connected to each other so these
are edges and edges connect one or more
nodes to each other they can also be
directional um so it could say like a
node of this type points at this node it
could have some information and attrib
on the edge as well so like a really
easy version of that um that we're going
to use for the simple implementation of
this is like nodes are people people of
attributes they have like time with
company or like languages known or
something like that and then we can have
edges that are like I manage somebody
and some what else manages that person
and so now we can create edges that
point from person to person create this
reporting structure thing that we had
before but now it's in the
graph great and what's the graph itself
uh it's composed of some nodes probably
some Ed too um and they're probably
related in some way um it can be
directional like I mentioned it doesn't
have to be directional either depending
on what kind of graph you're doing and
then um yeah the rest of it is just
implementation details that we can get
to Great anyone really concerned with
this is there have I slandered graphs or
anything like that are we okay yeah okay
good uh I don't want to start off like
that okay
so um if we had good data let's just
assume that which probably isn't true um
and we know people's reporting structure
which we did know from our other little
tool we can scrape that and get
information we can create a simple
directed graph so nodes are people edges
is this like management relationship uh
and we can plot it and it looks already
better than we had before um you can
start to see people who are cousins or
distant siblings um it's easier to
visualize more data because it isn't
just a big page or flat table of
information here like we see some people
reporting up into other folks um and we
just see like a kind of Chunk here on
the side but uh this is pretty good I
think it's a step up um can it be better
um that's I mean that's the whole point
I think it can be
so all we're seeing in the other graph
is this Management's relationship but
I'd like to see more relationships
between people so we already said that
like maybe we're a python developer and
we have a background in physics I don't
know if we all have a background in
physics uh or for all python developers
but maybe that's something that we want
to arise in this um so like what can we
point
to or how can we introduce this into our
graph so it turns out there's a couple
different ways to do it um and one of
them is to say let's have different
kinds of notes in the graph let's not
just have people let's have other stuff
like programming language or like team
name or like hiring date although there'
probably be a lot of those maybe you can
bucket up into like the year you were
hired I don't know if that's important
either um but we can start to plot these
and give them the same treatment as a
person in a graph and then connect
people to these nodes so now we have
like a special kind of node that's your
attribute node and then we can cluster
around these things so what it kind of
looks like and this one's a little bit
ugly we will make them look better later
um we could see different kinds of nodes
here and they're colored different ways
so we have people um and then the colors
of people are changing I guess based on
the team neon that might have been
happening here um but we also have
python Java
JavaScript um and we could introduce
more kinds of nodes as well and so
people here are being uh associated with
not just each other through this
management stream um but also to these
other attributes that they have and
share together um and
uh great and and now that we have this
information contained within the graph
what we really care about is how close
people are together um am I closer to
you because we share python or because
we share python Java and um we both
attended some event together maybe less
important here at the level we want to
dig into but um we can start to pull
those relationships together and uh the
kind of magic uh that allows us to do
that is there's a lot of different ways
to look at clustering and look at
closeness of these more higher
dimensional graphs um but a really
simple way is to just plot it and allow
like physics engine to solve um treating
the little nodes like like balls and the
edges like Springs that are pulling and
pushing each other and then allow it to
find an equilibrium point and now things
have been pulled closer together that
are more similar or more attached to
each other and things that are less uh
similar have been repulsed um and so we
can get an idea of closeness from that
cool um so what else can we do um we can
make this more interactive we can share
this with other people
and allow people to explore the kinds of
relationships and attributes that they
think are interesting and that's what
we're going to work towards fantastic um
this must be the end of the slides um
yeah this is the end of the slides
fantastic thanks for bearing with me
okay so um we're on to the notebook
section please feel free to follow along
in the little folders there are uh
there's like a workbook which is empty
and has some suggested pieces and at the
end of the workbooks we can just pull in
the results from the solution notebooks
um and work on those too
um yeah I think I'm going to try to just
kind of go through the solution pieces
and talk through it but feel free to
like on the little pieces uh yourself as
well awesome so um let's make sure we're
at a good size
here yeah
yeah just bear with me as I forget how
br ERS work
and where's 's full
screen yeah awesome so um we're gonna
going to kind of take a bit of a a side
turn here so we want to build graphs and
we want to have good data uh
unfortunately I can't just bring my
organization's data and give it to you
and so we're going to have uh a little
bit of a side lesson here about
generating nice synthetic fake data um
and we're going to do with python we're
going to explore this Library Faker
which is apply named uh and see if we
can develop something that like looks
like a group of people that might work
in a company together um and maybe enjoy
what they do although that part is
harder to say awesome so people what are
they how can we represent them in a
meaningful way um and by meaningful I
mean like I want them to look
statistically like real people um they
don't have to have like thoughts and
feelings but I think it would be great
if when we looked at this graph in this
future State like I don't know like 40
minutes from now we look at this graph
we like hey that kind of looks like what
people would look like if they worked in
a company like maybe they're like on
teams and like some of them know Python
and some of them don't right maybe more
people who like I don't know work in
engineering no python than people who
are in sales I don't know I don't know
how it works in this company but these
are the kinds of things that we want to
think about and we want to recover those
kind of Statistics at the end of the day
um from this fake data that we generate
so what is Faker um there's some great
docs here on it and we can look at those
if we wanted to um but uh it purports to
provide fake data for us and fake data
is what we want right now so it actually
has this function right out of the box
we can initialize
Faker um and yeah let me know if this is
too small or anything but we'll
initialize Faker and then it has
something called profile which is giving
us like a person right out of the box so
this is like the fastest sidetrack piece
of uh my talk so far um as long as like
this is actually good data which we'll
see U so yeah what does this look like
like some they have job company which is
great we care about what company they
work for it gives them a location and
where the residence is it's like maybe
more information than we needed blood
group I don't know probably drop that
one I don't think we want to find people
with the SAR blood types and introduce
them to each other that would be weird
um they have like multiple websites
associated with them the username okay
so there's like good stuff in here but
but uh it might not
be it might not be exactly what we need
you know but there's some good stuff and
and I like the idea of being able to run
this a couple times and getting uh
different things um yeah maybe like a
Furniture conservator restorer doesn't
work at our company um but maybe maybe
we're really into that but what we're
seeing is that if we run this a couple
different times we're seeing a a real
diversity of different things this is
not focused into maybe like what would
Happ in one single normal company um but
it's like very generally like thig
people around the world
um cool um so what else does Faker do um
Faker also allows you to pull out unique
values so we can say like you know give
me one of the things that Faker knows
about like your prefix uh or your name
or like a state that you live in um it
can also keep track of uniqueness so if
we wanted to make sure all of the user
ID were unique we could do that um and
so like here it's printing out all the
different prefixes that it knows about
and then eventually it throws an error
because it's run out of unique prefixes
right which is okay um but yeah I guess
I kind of alluded to this but we can go
in here and generate a few and just see
what it looks
like
uh we look at three of
them and uh yeah I mean we suspected
this uh we have an engineering geologist
which sounds cool I wish I did that a
Leisure Center manager um which probably
if we're a very large company we have a
Leisure Center so I kind of like that
that hasn't come up to be uh before uh
and a learning disability our
interesting also interesting I think I'm
having issues with this little
microphone though do we think that I
think that might be happening okay um
I'm just going to keep going so it's a
good start it's a little bit wonky I
wish it was better right um um so it
turns out we're not just stuck with this
one thing um the fer Library provides a
few different fields that it's already
prepopulated with lots of values it
allows you to register new providers uh
for new fields that you might be
interested in and expand upon that over
time um so really easily it has a thing
called a dynamic provider that looks
great uh you can name it um like
employment status and then give it the
uh possible values for it and then now
um we can run uh we can add it right and
then Generate random fake employment
statuses this is great I'm now like okay
I could build a person and know if
they're part-time contractor full-time
right um now like with this Dynamic
provider it's uniformly random so we're
going to have like a a uniform
distribution here of full-time contract
and part-time maybe that doesn't really
make sense um there's like a lot of
interns um maybe too many um love
interns but you know can't just the
interns or 13 interns I don't know um so
there's another provider for that as
well if you want to get a little more
into the weeds um so you can import this
base provider to extend the class and
here we can put in well whatever we want
we Define a function and this is what's
called when we try to return something
um and it'll keep uh it'll keep track of
the uniqueness as well so we're getting
some of those those built-in little
Magics from Faker as well so here did
the same thing again employment status
uh but we Define like a a different
ratio for each different status and then
uh I use some like I don't know random
choice to pick out what we want right
and so now we can do this and if I run
out a whole bunch of different times uh
I should get more full-time and contract
and much fewer part-time which you know
my very scientific exploration right now
of hitting enter seems to be showing so
I think we're happy with that okay so
this is this is like the building blocks
to we can use Baker for this but we're
still lacking a lot of the attributes
that we might care about in a tech
focused person so uh I tried to sketch
out some of them here as a starting
point um using a python data classes
which I think are kind of neat um and so
here there's
a like a time zone we can build a
location for everyone that consists of
like a city a time zone country that
seems good we could say a person has a
couple different
attributes like a name date they were
hired I kept saying that before um what
their employment status is we really
like I think the cool use case is like
what programming languages they know um
I think that's that's something fun to
try and find more people and build
communities if they don't already exist
um we need to know their manager because
we think this reporting structure piece
is important if we want to keep that
around um and then yeah if we can name
their team or like keep track of their
title that would be great um and then
location's nice um if
you're hypothetically we're building
some sort of like it's your first day
and who should your friends be and like
I think talk to one of these five people
they're in your time zone and they
started around your date and they like
the things you like maybe someone's a
little more seasoned and they're a
veteran and they know what how things
work so having all this information I
think gives us a good amount of data
that we could use in a model for this
like person recommender app great so we
can fill in this person
uh and give them I keep forgetting to
run the code so yeah so we can like
define a person now and they know some
languages and they live in a location
they're full-time great um now we just
need to fill this up um
so a couple things come up um there's
this little help beer function which is
like provides a random number of values
from a list and uh it provides the
number that it provides is also random
so specifically trying trying to solve
this programming language question like
we would think that people know zero or
more programming languages but probably
fewer people know eight programming
languages then know zero or one
programming language so there's there's
some distribution that we want to pick
from and maybe the more elegant solution
is here to like Define the distribution
for everything and then like sample from
it for everybody um but who has time for
that um we can just use a bunch of these
random choices embedded into each other
um why not uh so that's what this
function does uh we'll use it a couple
different
times okay so um what else can we do um
we already saw how we can extend Faker
to have new providers let's extend it
for programming languages so um here we
have some different weights for
different languages and then we Define
like how this choose a few function
works so now this is going to um provide
us with a random number from zero to
however many there are uh program
languages and then they're going to be
weighted as well so like some of them
are going to pop up more so at the end
of the day in our like statistical view
we should see like a pretty python heavy
shop with JavaScript and Java like a
little more heavy but kind of like
equally split and then some of the more
uh can I esoteric languages for them all
yeah some of the more esoteric languages
uh like elixir um maybe no one knows it
maybe 1% right um
cool uh so we can do that and we've got
our progam programming languages down um
now we can make a person um um
so uh at this point you know I think we
have a lot of the different pieces we
need we can put in a fake name for them
um we can take some start date and figer
has a date between so we can say like
everyone joined within the last three
years that's when we started the company
uh and pick a random start date that's
great and yeah and we put together their
employment status programming languages
but now we're a little bit stuck because
uh I want to assign everybody a team and
I think everyone should have a job title
and be in a location but I'm thinking
that maybe these things aren't
independent um definitely I think that
people's titles are probably tied to the
kinds of teams that they're on so like
it may not be crazy to have a an
engineer in a sales team um being like a
like a financial sales team let's say um
I know it's pretty common to have that
in a like proper tech company but um
yeah or you wouldn't have someone like a
an HR representative on the engineering
team um in fact I think that would be
for voted uh so we probably want to have
some relationships and then pick from
those again so we can follow the same
pattern we did with the programming
languages but with a little more
complexity and and try to sketch out
like what are the options like where are
geographically teams located what kind
of job titles are on the teams and what
distribution of job titles might fall
into the teams um and then hopefully we
can get something that looks a little
bit like a top- down organization where
people like report up to a manager and
then teams are managed by like somebody
who reports is on like a larger team
reports up and up and up uh forever
hopefully um that's how you know a
company is strong um lots of middle
management right okay yeah
um okay so we can make a person and and
we've done so cool so what I'm trying to
sketch out here is the idea that we have
these different places so we're
different teams and there's different
roles inside of them we can we can
sample from this right so this is what
it looks like um at least in this
implementation so we have teams like
developer experience devops sales
support platform product internal tools
business and then different titles
there's some overlap so hopefully we see
something interesting where like yeah
there's engineers in a couple different
teams or like
suborganizations um but there's probably
none in the business in this
implementation right uh we can also say
some teams are in certain offices but
not in others um we can play around with
this too to see what it looks
like uh and then we can go ahead and uh
and just to Define like where the
offices are so um in this case I said we
have a New York office Seattle office
Toronto London Fort Lauderdale and
Dublin right so a little bit little bit
Global and uh each of those will tie
back to the allowed teams per office
right um great now we just need to go
and pick the vote and uh in this case I
don't think we actually extended Faker
but you'll get something like we're
choosing the top level first which is uh
we're picking what what city we're in
and then we know only certain teams are
in that City and then we know only
certain titles are in that team with a
certain distribution okay uh so now
we're getting something that hopefully
looks a little bit um I don't know like
a normal company but really at this
point there's a lot of hand waving and
not a lot of proving it out uh so
hopefully we can actually like look at
this and see like does this at least
look right um what can we do to validate
this um sure yeah so this is like giving
me
some combinations of uh title City and
team love it fantastic okay um so now we
can update our make person and we can
make a person uh with a little more
depth to them that live in a real place
um fantastic uh then we can make 150 of
them and take a on a look at it so it's
kind of tough to look at the the real
distributions of people right now um
without going into a graph
implementation and trying to see uh that
like reporting structure relationship
but what we can do uh is do some like
basic uh visualization so um what are we
doing here
um okay so one more piece of this
probably before we can complete is
there's one more field we care about um
that we skipped and that's the manages
field right and so in this case and like
points if you have a better way of doing
this cuz gets a little bit nasty but uh
we need to assign everybody a manager
and probably that manager should be in
their team or their Department um and
maybe they have a job title that ranks
the same or higher than this person's
job title um like we could do it all
randomly and then everyone would be
randomly reporting to just someone in
the company which I think might work if
you were trying to introduce chaos into
the whole system and maybe that works
for you um sometimes I think that would
be better than what happens in real life
but um no like this kind of is how
things work right some engineer has a
managing engineer manager and then they
have another manager it goes on and on
forever right um cool so here we're
doing a little bit of like grouping by
grouping by the team and the title and
then try to find somebody who's like of
equal title or greater um inside your
team assigning them as like the sole
manager of the entire team um and this
is just laziness on my part and trying
to keep it simple
um but you could definitely optimize
this a bit to make it a little more
chaotic like in a good way introduce
little Randomness into the process so it
looks a little more real um but uh in
practice it will give us a manager field
uh and that will be shared for like this
team so um the last piece is we need to
have a CEO apparently uh and they should
probably have all the team leads
reported to them in the structure okay
uh now we' met all the requirements uh
to IPO and we're very happy and we can
actually start doing work um cuz I think
that's the order we do it in we hire
like 150 people then we start doing work
um come up with the idea later awesome
um great
so uh what are we doing here okay so the
last piece is we can flatten this down
uh the location piece down and then
actually visualize it so um at this
point we can do something pretty simple
um so this is a plotly plot and we can
just look at like does this make sense
uh and look at uh here we're seeing the
different teams people are on the
different countries they're in as faets
along uh the the x-axis there um and
then we're seeing um the different uh
different titles that they have yeah
so um yeah does this make sense uh in
Great Britain there are a lot of VPS uh
managing directors director of
presidents it looks like there's a lot
of people from the business here and
then also people from sales so I guess
that's what we defined it as and that's
what it ended up being so that's all
right uh it doesn't look entirely
trivial the way that it's set up as a
very vague hand waving thing uh there's
different amounts of different people
and different places my like uh gut
feeling um having cheated and already
done the rest of it but I gut feeling is
this like could be you a network of
people I think we might have some okay
data um but really in order to take the
next step and figure that out we need to
get this into a graph and then visualize
that graph and see if that makes
sense that's the theory I think we're
going to find
out fantastic okay so we can jump into
the next workbook now this is in the
part one the the like graphing
section um so we're going to be using
network X in order
to take all this data that we've
generated build its relationships into
it and then use a couple features of
network X to understand about
relationships people have but a lot of
it is going to be just as a vehicle to
hold this data together and then move it
into a format where we can visually
analyze it uh so what is Network X
fantastic python package uh for working
with graphs um really with networks of
any kind um it's fast um it's great
check it out and it works in memory um
some considerations you might have is
like it might be hard to grow this
really really really large since uh
we're limited to being in memory and you
have to come up with some ways to Shard
this or or distribute it across multiple
different uh processors um there's some
other tools that also do that for you
but uh the real power of of this is like
it's quite quick it's easy to use the
interface is nice uh and we can
interface with some other visualization
libraries pretty easily as well which is
pretty NE I like getting stuff for
free okay so um Network apps how does it
work
so the first thing we do is we make a
graph and then we're very happy so we
have a graph now we can initialize this
and then fill it up with data and then
start to use the uh inherit methods of
this graph to find out more about it so
adding nodes is easy
um you create something with an ID uh or
a name or a
label um you can provide other
attributes as keyword arguments when
you're adding it right uh and it
supports um more complex um objects
being embedded inside of it uh like
lists the most complex object but um
really we can build this out just like
you would you can think of it like a
dictionary implementation under the hood
but we can build out highly nested
things and and still access this
information uh and then build
relationships between the nodes right um
probably we won't be manually adding
single nodes at a time in our code base
so it's good to know that you can add
nodes from iterators as well uh so here
we can say like I'm adding from this uh
this uh tubal that I created here um two
different nodes with uh um some names
and then some other property inside of
them right um we like that that's great
uh we can view the nodes so this shows
us like the names of the nodes we can
also see the underlying data associated
with the nodes and so we can say data
equals true and this will print out uh
those underlying like uh objects that
we're storing our attributes in and if
we want to we can also pull out uh just
attributes that we want to look at at a
given time as well so here I'm saying
just give me the languages for each
person um forget about the whatever the
other attributes we put in are and we
can pull that out for each person and
it's a nice mapping between person to
this attribute so this is a good way to
access those other uh those um
attributes U when we scale this up to be
much larger great
um right and uh what's a graph without
Edge and so we can also add edges to
connect these people together uh so me
and you um were connected by being
friends and you and them are also being
connected by being friends which is
great um I don't know I don't want to
spoil this but it's going to be fun um
so you got asking questions now like
what's the shortest path between me and
them uh and the answer would be it's
through you because I'm friends with you
and you're friends with them um or we're
friends together it's not necessarily
Direct hopefully it's bir directional
right um we can also print out things
like an adjacency M Matrix to see all
the different ways that things connect
to each other and how they're connected
what edges are connecting things uh and
built into it is a little visualization
Library uh that leverages mat plot lib
and so we can plot this fantastic graph
relationship that we've just built um
the foundation for everything um which
is me you and them all connected through
friendship and uh fantastic we like
this um so now we know how to build
graphs we know how to load them up with
data and we know how to visualize the
graph and its structure right this one's
very simple um it's a line but uh
potentially it could get more
complicated so uh let's pull in and
reuse what we used before and then try
to load that into our graph uh so I
think at the end of the thing before we
ended up with a a data frame uh um of
that we fled out with all the attributes
of our people in it I think at another
Point there's like a list of these
person objects that were created um that
you could also use um and those like
python data classes are really easy to
serialize into Json uh so you should be
able to do that as
well
awesome uh yeah so this is pretty hacky
and there are better ways to do this but
we're running the old notebook that we
or rerunning that and then just pulling
in all those
variables um again I welcome PLL
requests you know let's make this better
uh but it works and uh it hasn't gone
wrong yet um fantastic I'm just going to
keep zooming in every few minutes until
we're at maximum uh fantastic okay so
the graph uh now we're ready to pull in
um people from our Network graph so um
turns out uh there's an semi- elegant
way to do this
uh we can iterate over all those
elements in our data frame uh I mean
like I know iterating over the data
frame is a bad word but it had to be
done I'm sorry uh we can add those nodes
uh taking the person's name as their ID
and then that whole rest of the person
um node and dump at that those
attributes as attributes into the graph
into the graph node uh we can also
assign additional information while
we're doing this so here um for
historical Legacy reasons uh we labeled
the as person as an attribute being true
and also their type being person uh
because someone got lazy while they were
making this and forgot uh what they were
calling everything um
fantastic
um also pitch for more it tools it's
very useful s um great so these are
three people from our graph um we can
see I mean we already saw this
information this was in a data frame it
really looks like a dictionary right now
or a tuple of we a list of tupal of
strings and dictionaries right um but
we've got our people we've generated
them and they're in our graph now so
here's the first three of them um in
theory we can finally get to the thing
that we've been trying to do uh for the
last X minutes uh where X is much larger
than 10 or 20 um and I think we can
visualize so um let's use this great map
plot Li visualizer and take a look at
the graph and it's not really great uh
because we forgot add all the edges in
and all the nodes are just little blobs
in the circle so we do want to add some
more um loveliness to it uh a little bit
of color probably first uh so maybe we
want to color the nodes with some
attribute information we want to drive
our visualization by some properties in
it and so if we want to we can come in
here and find out like all the unique
teams from our data set and assign a
color to that that team name right and
then we can replot um the nodes with
colors but we also want to get to edges
right um so let's not let not drag our
feet
there great uh so it turns out when
you're drawing uh with the network X
Library uh you can provide either like a
a color uh or a map uh or this list of
colors and that will inform how nodes
are colored when you draw them and so we
can go through and convert it to the
format we want um here we're just like
pulling from some plotly color scale
that looked interesting Vivid because it
sounds very exciting and we are pumping
that into the format that Network X
wants for its node colors and then we
can draw it and you know as I luded to
before we're still missing the edges but
we can see there's some distribution of
different teams that people are on
that's it's fantastic I like
that um great and so it's also
um an an easy to use interface and
network X to pull out um The Edge
relationships we want so because one of
the attributes that we want to use to
build the edges is manager um we can
just pull that out all at once using the
data equals you know attribute name um
method that we were looking at before uh
and in this one liner we can add all of
those
relationships
um into edges in our graph and then also
label them as like something that we'll
want to use later so we'll say they're
manager edges right and then manager
equals true because we did that same
thing again um and just to be clear like
what this looks
like um when we do our little node call
here we're pulling out essentially a map
of like employee to manager um for each
note in the graph uh and then eventually
somebody the CEO will have no manager or
they'll be their own manager I don't
really remember what we did there but uh
you know probably either of those would
be a good way to terminate uh the end of
this uh Hier hierarchical structure
great so that loads in nicely and we can
draw it and oops I didn't run the code
again uh lo and behold this looks like
something right this looks in my mind a
little bit like what company would look
like um if they had really large teams
right so maybe like we could do better
with this and get a little more you know
depth to the teams and maybe have some
different reporting in there but we can
see some clear team structures people
are reporting up towards a central
figure uh let's say pat on the back um
we built something that looks vaguely
like a mediumsized company of however
many I think there's 150 people in this
company um we can work with this let's
try to find relationships between these
people now so this is a little bit
harder to do with uh with networkx um
with the the like out of the box uh map
plot Li plotting it's hard for us to
show um more attributes and more
dimensionality here uh so one thing we
can do to try and take a deeper look
into this is to uh use a library like
plotly um you could do this also with
like alter do Bou or like I don't know
any any number of these more advanced
plotting libraries that have things like
a hover data or like um more of a
grammar of Graphics approach that allows
you to put more dimensionality baked
into the image um essentially um but
let's take a stab at it with
plotly um so what we're trying to do
here is um do a little bit of the steps
that map plot lib and network X are
doing behind the scenes and so we want
to take our graph we want to uh turn
that into XY coordinates so we can
actually plot that um so there's a
couple different ways to do that in
network X um one of the simpler and um
more efficient ways is to use a spring
layout um where we do like a little bit
of a physics solve and then it plots out
where everything should be um we take
our X and Y coordinates for each um node
now and we can plot that with a scatter
plot right and then what we basically
want to do is be able to pass in a
couple other parameters in order to
influence how maybe uh the coloring of
the nodes is based on an attribute
inside the node as well as something
like uh if we wanted to make facets in
the plot um anything that you would do
if you're familiar with plotly or with u
like grammar of Graphics approach to
plotting um we want to be able to get
that magic for free right uh if if
possible um so this a little helper
function to do that um which is mostly
like I mentioned making a Sprint layout
uh is making a scatter plot down here uh
and then also passing in these uh
different parameters to plot and let it
do its magic with the Gramm Graphics
right um fantastic it also adds edges
based on whatever we Define as being
like the The Edge attribute um so
everything we did so far uh it's going
to do that for us um and great we can
actually plot something
so uh this is plotted with the edges off
but if we wanted to um now like this is
pretty much what we had before um what's
good about this approach is we can
actually come in and start to
investigate some of these points on a
point BYO basis as well and see if this
makes sense uh on on our I don't know
there's this look like the kind of thing
that's a a person organization uh so in
the middle year we have Jordan Harper
the CEO this is good they we wanted them
in the middle you know the the code
Works uh reporting to them are a few
different people um some business people
we have someone over here who's the
manager of a lot of people they seem to
be the head of the sales team okay this
is sales they're in Great Britain um and
they have a variety of different
titles um like they this still looks
right okay um and we can use this and
this uh sort of like Little Helper
function to take a couple different
plots and see um like we don't have to
group people by reporting structure
necessarily we don't have to um size the
plot the the the nodes by how far they
are from the center we can color it by
things other than just like what team
they're on because we already know teams
should be um teams should be grouped
together because they report into each
other um we could come in here and see
like yeah can we plop by country and so
we see a little more distribution of
people because teams aren't always in
the same country and so we have some
like mixing of colors over here as we
have like a
these people are in Toronto New York and
London but they all are part of the uh
and whatever team this is what is this
sales the sales team so you know we we
have some interesting structure and we
can investigate that now with this tool
um so definitely like play around with
it and see if it makes sense the
distribution so this is taking our our
kind of naive bar plot of the flat data
set and then introducing it some of this
higher dimensionality what we're looking
at
still this management reporting
structure and seeing if this
distribution makes sense okay um cool so
there's another tool that also um is
good for this um is pretty interesting
so P so it uses another JavaScript
library behind the scenes um but what's
neat about it is we can get um like a
live physics engine to
animate um which you know is exciting
for us we like
that and yeah this one wasn't colored
but uh we can kind of like zoom in hover
over things still and explore what they
are but we get this like the thing you
were promised which is like the draggy
droppy uh yeah right like everyone loves
that um that's what we're here for uh
cool but uh we can extend the function
as well and sort of put together this
thing that's kind of the same as the
plotly one where we can Define um like
how we want to color it what value
should be the textt and what the hover
value should be as well and uh we can do
that for
uh for our plot and say like uh yeah
that's color colors are teams uh the
label should be the person's title um
and then title is like um the the hover
text it's just like the names that P
used for things um that should be the
city that they're in and so we have this
like kind of fun looking fireworks
display uh with a really janky looking
Legend which is just other nodes that we
injected on the side um there are some
limitations to some of these libraries
um but the magic is uh we can come in
and investigate over here and uh well I
mean the magic is still that we get to
pull around the little notes um just
like it it it's the gift that keeps on
giving really um do we get a lot more
out of this I feel much more confident
and pleased with uh our coding um so I
think just that peace of mind is worth
it okay
perfect okay so what have we done so far
it's hard to remember um we made some
fake people we like them we built out
some um some like plot plot helpers to
visualize the different networks graphs
that we created uh we played around with
the fun firework noes and very exciting
um but how do we share this with
somebody else so somebody can come in
here and run our code and tweak the
different values they can say like
instead of looking at you know like
teams as different colors maybe I want
to see um like programming languages and
like who knows python right like that's
something we probably want to see
um but if somebody is less technically
inclined right how do we share this with
someone else so the next piece I want to
dive into is how do we turn this from
like it's interactive in the sense that
it's in a jupit or notebook and you can
change the code and run it and see the
results absolutely but can we serve this
in a different way um to really meet our
goal of making this careerfinder app or
this tool that we can give to somebody
on day Zero or day one depending on uh
how your couny system is uh and help
them find their people right in the
company
great so there's two things we still
want to tacle right one is we still
don't know what programming languages
people know um that wasn't in our graph
we need to introduce those attributes
into the graph um and then we also want
to be able to share that in an
interactive way with people okay so um
this is just rerunning the old
notebooks cool
so basically what we want to do um mean
spoiler we need to add those nodes into
the graph uh so we can iterate through
through our graph right determine which
attributes we care
about and then map those back into the
graph with some other identifier so we
know that they're not people there's a
couple ways to do this as well um this
way does work but uh depending on how
complicated you want to get with your
graph uh you can also Define um uh
bipartite graphs and so uh the different
nodes will live on like a different
layer in the graph and this is innately
built into the the graph
um if you're if you're interested in
yeah definitely check it out if you're
interested in that it's a little more
complicated to manage it which probably
the right way to do this um this way
though is quite simple to implement and
we can still get the visual
representation that we like and we can
still filter out notes um based on these
um like these flags that we're putting
in to say like this is a person or this
is a language or this is like a country
right and so we can identify the
different kinds of notes but there's a
more formal way to do it as well with
the network graph Network a framework if
you're interested in that okay um great
so this is using the same uh approach we
did before we're going through nodes um
pulling out a specific attribute that's
a map right now between people and
attributes and then we're adding those
as nodes in um great and so we can do
that for languages say cities time zones
right and uh probably we can just take a
look at get that now and it could be
exciting uh great and then we want to do
the same thing for for edges so now
we've added in um I mean we can go and
look at what we've actually added in
here um but what we should see is
uh somewhere at the bottom um we should
have the people stop you know Brian
Carter Devin Hub erlang Java Javas
typescript right so we just have like
these other nodes now intermingled with
the nodes of our people and we need to
connect those nodes just like we
connected people to people as a manager
Edge we want to connect people to
attributes as an attribute Edge so
someone will connect to erling that's
why ear langang is in there um great and
that information is also available um in
our node View and so we can pull this
information out really easily and this
is a great thing that the graph
representation could do um once we're
starting to build these relationships
it's really easy to pull out those
relationships great um cool so we can go
ahead and just add those edges um from
attributes for
language time zone city right just uh
for our example here and then we can
draw it so
uh in this case we're using that plotly
plotter thing that we did before and we
can take a look at the different kinds
of uh nodes that are in here now so
and we still have people being related
by their management structure um
actually we could do this
again I think this one's just fun
looking but uh U so we can still see
people are grouping by management
structure but they're being pulled apart
now by these other nodes so uh I also
see that we didn't plot up edges so want
to do
that
I think both of these get a little more
complicated now in the rendering time
the javascript's like really chugging in
the back trying to trying to render it
oh okay yeah so we can see this like
really wild
uh uh relationship between people um the
default settings of the physics engine
is unable to find an equilibrium right
now so we could tweak that if we really
wanted to but um yeah we kind of have
the thing swimming around where oops
sorry uh people are related by
management structure still wow we're
just zoom in everywhere here um related
by management structure but they're also
being pulled into these other nodes uh
which are like a language node and so
people have multiple edges um so I think
this is a pretty good visual of like
what's happening before we find
equilibrium in the physics engine uh
where people are being pulled together
that weren't together before um so it
might happen at a larger macro level
like the engineering and the devop team
might get pulled together because they
all know python right in a simple
conceptual example but we should see
more like highle patterns arting this SP
um is a little bit meem mesmerizing um
and you know that's why we do what we do
um so a more static version that's uh
easier on the eyes kind of um is we can
see like llang here is connected to two
people um it doesn't seem to be really
influencing this
um but things like python uh or Scala
are starting to have more large scale um
effects and trying to like pull or or
leverage uh the edges of the graph uh in
order to pull or push things closer or
further
toart
um which is interesting that's what we
kind of want to do uh now we could spend
more time trying to doctor this and make
it look better but um I don't know if
that's worth our time right now we want
to look at another visualization
framework uh using plotly and Dash um
called cytoscape another JavaScript
library um it's going to allow us to
build a more interactive piece where we
can tweak what we want to do in terms of
like styling coloring the nodes but then
also determine like how many of these uh
attributes to introduce at once we know
that if we introduce too many of them
like maybe in here it becomes a little
bit chaotic and sorry the it's always
the opposite of what I think I'm
pinching is what's happening on my
screen and so anyways we don't want to
be too too chaotic or at least be able
to back air once we've done that and not
have to go and regenerate the whole
thing all the time um so there's a
couple different things you can do at
this point now that we have a graph that
has attributes embedded into
it um we can look at actually answering
the question now non-visually so you can
go and say like what is uh the like a
circle of closeness around a certain
point like give me my 10 closest people
in this graph um that's absolutely
something you can do now um and we can
get back a list of those points that's
great um we can also like view the graph
and or sorry we can render the graph um
this might be more intuitive uh but you
can render the graph and then look at um
the X Y coordinates of everything and
find the distance right and draw a
circle and say like okay I only picked
up 10 people inside of this you can also
leverage uh the connectivity of the
graph and look at how many steps away
you are from someone and if we share a
lot of attributes I'm only one step away
from you for all those attributes right
but we can also get an idea of higher
level connections where uh teams might
be related through somebody else like
you and I don't know I'm sort of waving
my hands around but like the sales team
might work really closely with the
engineering team who works closely with
the devops team and so sales is closer
to devops than they are to somebody who
doesn't work with the either team right
even though they may never need in
person um but we will make them meet I
guess as part of this uh FriendFinder
yes your audience find
result yeah I don't I don't know it's a
good question so in the GU of this this
experiment it was all about you're
starting in a company and it's like how
do you find people that like the kind of
things that you like um but you can use
Network graphs to represent lots of
different kind of relationships right
and if you were digging more into like
how people are interacting um and I
think like these are things that a
couple of the large Tech uh platforms
provide as well like you can look at in
Outlook you can see uh the people who
are in your your your like neighborhood
that you chat with or you email the most
and that could be interesting on an
organizational level in terms of
proficiencies or just like how are
people connected another thing that we
do internally is we have like an
appreciation program where you can send
each other like thank you cards with
like a nominal monetary value associated
with it and so it would be really
interested to see people who are like
thanking themselves a lot but then also
just how are people connected right um
what kind of like how how are teams
recognizing each other that's something
interesting as well um and you know just
be nice about it and don't be creepy um
which is all the you know whenever we're
dealing with people data it always comes
down to that um great so those are a
couple ways that you can uh look at uh
people and their connectivity just uh
using the features of the network graph
now but we're going to push on and look
at it more from a visual sense and try
to get this interactive component into
it um yes that's
that great so uh for the next section
um this is a sort of like a continuance
on top of using plot Le before to do
plotting um but we want to be able to
have that nice
interactive um like visual that looks
pleasing but we also want to be able to
tweak it um over time and I don't know
like generate a whole bunch of different
versions of this plot um depending on
our inputs and explore and do some of
like what we could do in the code in a
Jupiter notebook um but potentially
without code and um something that we
could give to people we can like share
this as an application so one way to do
that is to use uh plotly Dash and so
this is uh like a react and flask um
framework um that's allows you to like
build a web
application um with callbacks um and
it's all python you know at least at the
at the coding level um but it's going to
let us put our our Network graph up
there and then build some sort of
interactive some tools like a input
boxes drop downs uh and then style
things dynamically as we go right um so
a very simple way um we can illustrate
it by just looking at it and kind of
like what this does um so we can import
the library we can create the Dash app
um and then we Define HTML like
wireframe layout so this doesn't have
any intelligence to it it's just HTML
elements um and so you know if you're
familiar with HTML it Maps one to one to
like what the actual tags are tags are
for HTML uh Cod so here we have like the
the page will be one big div inside of
it will be a header header one and then
we'll have a paragraph that says
structure things like you would in HTML
and then we have a button the button
says click me to do something it's very
provocative um that's that's important
in app design um the other piece of a
very simple Dash app so we could just
run that and it'll be a static HTML web
page which is already great you didn't
have to write too much code Ser in side
of this uh python thing pretty easily um
the other piece is we want to add some
Dynamic components to this like I have a
button I want to be able to click the
button I wanted to do something and
change the way that the page behaves so
this is done with callbacks so I can
Define this app and Define a call back
and uh give it the inputs and outputs so
whenever an input changes uh in this
case we defined uh the input is that
thing called button um so the thing with
id id equals button
and then um the value that we're looking
at watching to see if it changes is like
the number of clicks that it has um when
that changes we're going to run this
python function um we're going to take
the input of like whatever this input
was in this case we don't really care
about what the input was but we can
print it out sure why
not uh and then we're going to return
something and the return gets pumped
into uh the output that we Define in
that decorator and in this case it's uh
this thing title uh
um which was the the like big header on
the top of the page right um cool so we
can actually run that and uh here cover
your eyes I'm going to switch back to
light theme um uh so this is going to
make a little application um right now
it's embedded uh and running like behind
the scenes right and I've embeded a
little if frame and the notebook but it
also exists at like Local Host
888880 um and it's a little h and it
looks as you would expect it
to um yeah I don't know why now I'm
going to start filling with the
microphone that seems like a bad idea
like it's going to get I'm going to make
it worse okay uh so we have this static
web page it it does look like how you'd
imagine if you see HTML and you like
imagine what it looks like if you've
been conditioned to behave that way um
like I have um and it has this button
that we can click and the button is
going to do something right and I click
it and it updates the HTML magic right
amazing I mean it's not magic it's some
cod um there even better than
magic uh yeah so that's great um now we
have all the pieces that we need uh to
in Python in this notebook build an app
that could be interactive that I
promised although I haven't shown you
actually does live at a web address and
and is available to people to look at
great um oh and the little print
statements that I made or doing
something to in case you debug with
printing which you know might happen
Okay
so now we can look at something a little
bit more
complicated uh and uh the the major
drawback of the plotly dash uh Library I
love it work with it a lot um when you
format it using like one of the Python
formatters you get this like massively
IND indented piece uh it's the only it's
the only real drawback of the whole
Library
um I can't it's it's not that bad okay
so we're going to introduce a couple new
things here so one of them is we can use
bootstrap components uh there's also
mantin components which look nice as
well um but I'm really just looking for
the simplest way to make this look nice
without having to work too hard um which
has really been the approach we've been
taking throughout the day um so here we
can start to use bootstrap components
just like HTML components and we can put
a little nav bar into the app and call
it communities and network graphs which
sounds vaguely like the topic title for
this talk um we can make a bootstrap
container inside the container can be
rows and columns because that's what
bootstrap
[Music]
wants and then um in this case it's a
little just demonstration of a more
complicated layout with bootstrap so we
have some like l myoms in there that we
can
generate uh and we can use like
bootstrap stuff like input groups so it
looks kind of nice uh and allow you to
input I don't know the number of
paragraphs of text to generate um in
another input group we can say like oh
let's choose the color of the text as
well that would be exciting uh and then
have a drop- down where we can pick from
some different values uh so in this case
you you provide the options for it and
it'll make a drop down for you and those
will be available in the call back in
order to influence something else in
your code we can also just style things
directly
um we can also just do
that
great and then in terms of the actual
smarts of the app uh in the Callback uh
what we're doing is we're looking at
those two inputs that we made so one was
the N paragraphs Dro down or I think it
was like a a numerical input right and
so whenever the value of that changes
we'll trigger this call back and then
similarly whenever the color drop down
changes we'll trigger this call back and
we will print them out because we're
doing that and then we'll return uh some
output so we're going to use Faker
Library throw back to Faker still here
uh and we'll generate some fake
paragraphs of text and we'll also style
the color of the text right um great so
we can do that and we have a little
bootstrap app it looks kind of nice we
can turn off the number of paragraphs
and getp paragraphs kind of wish the
paragraphs were longer though and not
just like two sentences but that's okay
and we can pick colors so we can make it
blue or like green and uh or black
that's nice um great so now we have a
couple more tools to make this look nice
and now we just need to make our graph
render it and then be able to toggle
like how we're grouping colors right and
then
maybe uh which uh attributes are being
included in the clustered attribute
graph right that's what we want to get
to an interactive way to do that so
luckily um by chance uh we've been
writing everything along so far as like
nice little functions that can be reused
and it's not going to be too tough to
regenerate our graph with different
combinations of color or different
combinations of those attributes inside
of
it um and here's just like everything
we've done so far that's a nice reminder
uh awesome so we have a couple functions
we want to make um one is we want to
create a graph so we want to regenerate
our graph but only add the attributes
that we want to add to it right and so
previously we were creating it and then
manually using this like ad nodes from
we had an attributes uh
like what was it attributes
uh keyword Arc or something in our
function to do that so we can reuse that
we're using this pattern of adding nodes
from um and then we're just picking the
right attribute for it to do that we add
in the the man attribute first and then
for the whole list of attributes we're
passing in we'll go through pull all
those out and then add those in with
this like new flag attached to it uh and
then add the edges because we can't
forget the edges so that's great we can
create a graph now and then we can
create uh the elements uh
so that's this is
uh yeah the I'm try trying to race a
little bit now but
uh We've created our graph now in
network X but we need to load this into
cytoscape now so turns out cytoscape
likes something similar to network X and
network X has an output method to put it
into a cytoscape format um but basically
what we're doing is taking the nodes and
the edges opening the format that
cytoscape likes uh and then including
those in a big list of elements um that
we're then going to uh give into ccape
graph um great so now we have a create
graph function that's called by our
create elements function it takes the
attributes in now now we should be able
to make a drop down um to pick which
attributes regenerate the elements pass
that into our graph and visualize it um
similarly we want to approach that with
our stylesheet so in the Styles sheet we
want to have maybe some some person
we're focused on U maybe they're
highlighted uh but uh in the cytoscape
uh world there's a whole uh format for
like how to how to style the nodes that
are existing in the graph H it uses uh
this approach called selectors so you
can select different things based on
patterns so here we're saying um we're
building the stylesheet and we're saying
all nodes uh should have a certain font
size and a certain color um depending on
like this variable that we put into this
function right um but we can go a little
more in depth and use uh logical
selectors as well so uh here we're
saying like edges uh that are languages
um we should style in a certain way um
so here we're saying like we want to put
labels on each of these different
connections and like someone who manages
someone should be labeled manages
somebody who codes in Python it should
say codes python uh lives in time zone
things like that so we can go through
and put these into our selectors as well
uh and ccape will be able to magically
not so magically render them which is
great um similarly like people we want
to actually put their names down under
their uh node um and if they're not a
person we'll do something else so we we
can build up this style sheet and
customize it uh but we want to do what
we want to be able to do uh and the key
piece here is that we want to be able to
color um the nodes based on this
attribute so we want to say like the
color of
um uh all of the language should be
based on the name of the language and
then and you people should well great um
so we can do that here in this little
function right so note color style sheet
we're going to spit out a little
selector Styles sheet as well um in this
case we're going through all the
possible colors uh and we're going to be
coloring them based on um that actual
attribute value and so in the Lector we
can say the node if the node has uh the
attribute equal to M value um to that
way what's great about this is we don't
have to do it at a node by node level we
can Define it at a stylesheet level uh
so it saves on like sending a whole
bunch of runda data around uh which is
also nice cool so what does it look like
in uh in Patrick uh who's Patrick in
practice um so we're using the dash
components we used before we're also
going to be using uh an extending
package Das cytoscape and so we can
import that um we're making our app just
like like before this time I called it
dashboard this is just my Dash app uh I
gave it a dark themed style sheet uh cuz
that's cool and uh we can Define some
layout parameters for
cytoscape look them up if you're
interested but this is a like some
hardcoded values that worked well in my
testing for how the physics engine
behaves um some like requirements things
like how repulsive nodes are um it
looked kind of nice when we found a good
value for it um
um things like node Dimension includes
labels is kind of important otherwise
you'll have nodes getting close together
and their their labels will overlap the
downside being that now we have like
really big boxes around nodes with
people have long names and you can get
this kind of grid effect that might
happen um where we don't have as much uh
as many like degrees of freedom around
noes uh to PLP them nicely um great um
now we can Define the different drop
downs that we want just like before uh
um this is really copy pasted from
before and tweaked a bit so we want to
be able to tweak which attributes we
show um so like let's pick some to start
with but anything from the list of
attributes uh in our uh node we should
be able to pick and then when that
happens we want to go and redraw the
graph with all those attributes as nodes
and the edges and then look at that
right similarly we want to control the
color and great these are going to map
to those inputs to the functions and we
just did great
um cool in terms of what it looks like
in the app uh so we're still building
the layout like wireframe layout for the
app um and to build the graph component
U we just need to put in this cytoscape
object we give it an ID just like a
normal Dash component uh and we provide
it with what its layout is um that those
are the instructions for like how the
physics engine should work what
restrictions are put on it um what the
solver is um we can make it responsive
so it'll be a little bit Dr draggy but
not super draggy and then a style so
like that piece is pretty empty um we're
going to be filling it up with the
Styles sheet and the elements based on
the call backs that we make at based on
the user
input and and then here's some junk just
for the website version of it where
there's links to stuff like I don't know
the the talk I don't know we put
something in we're making it a little
bit of interesting for all audiences um
cool so we assign the layout to the app
and then we can Define our call
so in terms of the callbacks um
hopefully they're kind of
straightforward but what we wanted to do
what we said we want to do is when
attributes change in that drop down we
want to redraw the graph with those
attributes in the graph so here we have
our
callback the input is that attributes
drop down and the output is the elements
of the network graph okay uh and then
inside the actual call function we're
taking the attributes and then we're
passing to that create elements function
great similarly for color when the color
drop down changes uh we're going to
redraw the Styles sheet and update
that um and we're going to do that with
the F Styles sheet function uh so now we
should be able to run this and see it in
practice um and we should get an error
that's good what do we do
wrong oh we we didn't run the code again
we have to run the
code somebody should be running the
[Music]
code this
one great great so this is what we are
trying to do it's pretty similar view to
what we've already seen um and we can
zoom in we can kind of explore these
nodes a little bit um but right now what
we're seeing is we've plotted our
attribute nodes for the team name still
the manager relationship to to connect
people together and then the city that
people are in and so we can see the high
level relationships where we're seeing
like the support team appears to be in
Dublin uh and so is the devops team or
some of the devops team um all of the
devops team yeah um and we can see these
relationships but we can also go and
explore this and so I can say like uh
don't plot team let's replot this let's
just see City and manager but let's
throw in languages to and so now we can
you know maybe drop manager and look at
relationships with people in different
cities so now we seeing people in London
uh disproportionately no Elixir um and
folks in Seattle uh seem to be like
grouped together more around Scala that
seems to be a common theme around the
Seattle and SE
seatt could have practiced that one
before uh we can also fiddle around with
color and you can see we can add more of
this over time to look at more
dimensionality for this but we're
building out this interactive piece uh
that somebody could use
maybe on day one to understand more
about
um yeah like what uh kind of work or
what other people are working on who's
similar to them um and things like that
in theory if I zoom doing here we have
people's names too but uh I think it
gets a little bit a little bit hairy
with all the lines everywhere so you
know there is a limit to how many um
additional um I don't know attributes
can be added in before it becomes like a
giant mess um and we don't want the
giant mess right so uh anyways giant
mess is fun too so this is what we
wanted to build uh a big messy
exploratory application is taking
together all the different pieces of our
uh exploring the network graph of our
fake people uh and then trying to get
some value out of it right um cool so
those are all the pieces I wanted to go
through thanks for coming along for the
ride does anyone have questions or
thoughts or or anything at this stage
which is the end stage just to clarify
that P
to awesome oh yeah you have any code for
the community detection that you can
show
us yeah for Community detection like to
do it non visually but with uh just code
or yeah yeah yeah I know they'll take
your while to it out visual but at least
yeah definitely so in one of these um
yeah there's a couple um a couple like
approaches you could take to looking at
this
so um kind of talk through it but uh one
is to look at how connected things are
to to each other how many steps you are
away from somebody um so that that can
be an interesting way to look at things
but it's missing some of dimensionality
so um what we're seeing when we Vis
visually see things is I may be
connected to you um I may be a step or
two away from you because we're
connected through python or we're
connected through um being full-time
employees right um but the other
connections that we don't share together
are meaningful in trying to determine
how close we are together um and so that
that is lost when you're only looking at
like the steps uh of the the number of
steps between nodes um because you're
not looking at like the distance between
noes as well so you can look at that as
well and you can waight the edges based
on like the distance are being pulled
apart by this too that's another way to
do it and then you can look at like a a
path traversal algorithm to see like
who's closest or um what's the easiest
way to get between people kind of
similarly it's it would be an
interesting use case to look at um like
how connected you are to specific people
like oh I want to have an introd
introduction to so and so like oh we
both share these attributes but they're
really close to so and so that I know
like those could be interesting use
cases too okay so like the that's the
ego graph is the number of uh steps you
are with you at the center um you can
also look
at like plotting this and taking all the
positions um the more advanced way to do
it is you would take these nodes and
then plot it in a vector space and then
you can use typical machine learning
algorithms to like find the find a
cluster things like you with vectors um
Vector space so those are all ways that
we can do that more uh with code and not
just looking at the visuals
great yeah if anyone has questions later
like feel free to reach out or pull me
aside and ask them whatever but uh yeah
it's been great thanks for everyone for
uh coming out
[Applause]
listening